U.S cyber security priorities the trust
radius winter best of awards and new
icct certifications all on this episode
of IBM Tech now what's up y'all my name
is Ian and I am back to bring you the
latest and greatest news and
announcements about IBM technology
start things off this week I wanted to
quickly look at a recent White House
fact sheet that outlines the current and
future U.S cyber security priorities
While most of the topics covered were in
line with expectations others Drew more
attention and were a bit of a surprise
the emphasis on critical infrastructure
protection shows it is clearly a top
National priority as it should be
the White House also stressed the
importance of developing Quantum
resistant encryption
Quantum machines powerful enough to
crack encryption keys are likely a
decade or more away but unexpected
breakthroughs happen and the risk is
real
for this reason we must develop stronger
cryptographic systems starting now
to this end the National Institute of
Standards and Technology announced four
new encryption algorithms as part of its
post-quantum cryptographic standard
one of the more surprising initiatives
was proposing the development of an
Internet of Things labeling program
essentially the U.S is looking to label
iot devices so that Americans can easily
recognize which devices meet the highest
cyber security standards to protect
against hacking and other cyber
vulnerabilities
to learn more about the White House fact
sheet and all the cyber security
priorities it covers check out the link
in the description of this video
next up I'm thrilled to announce that 18
IBM offerings have secured a spot in the
truss radius best of winter 2023 list
the trust radius quarterly Awards
provide buyers with useful Direction
when navigating product research and
consideration
in the winter 2023 best Awards showcased
the strongest scores for best feature
set best value for price and best
relationship
in IBM products including IBM API
connect db2 and turbonomic one Awards in
all three categories additionally
planning analytics with Watson when the
best feature set and best relationship
distinctions and cognos analytics with
Watson when the best features set award
to learn more about the trust radius
Awards hit the link below
to close things out today let's take a
look at two new certifications from the
IBM Center for cloud training the IBM
Cloud for VMware Solutions certification
shows you how to design build and run
VMware environments efficiently in IBM
Cloud the curriculum features a
portfolio of five different VMware
offerings includes the opportunity to
earn a digital badge as you progress
the IBM Cloud for sap certification
shows you how to migrate and run sap and
its Associated applications in the cloud
it also provides an understanding of
infrastructure as a service and
Architectural environments that make
running sap workloads affect
icct is also excited to offer an updated
professional architect certification
program that has been redesigned for
today's IT professional IBM Cloud
architecture
to learn more about icct and these
certifications hit the link below
thanks so much for joining me today for
this episode of IBM Tech now if you're
interested in learning more about the
topics I've covered make sure you
explore the links in the description of
this video and again please don't forget
to subscribe to our channel to stay up
to date on what's going on in Tech now